hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
a significant portion of book 10 of
augustine's confessions is focused on
the faculty or power of memory which is
not something completely unique to human
beings other animals have memory but
there is a greater range and depth to
the powers of memory that we have as the
kind of beings that we are that
augustine explores and it's worth noting
that at certain points he comes close to
equating memory with the mind because it
plays such an absolutely central
role now why is he so interested in
memory well these are the confessions
and he's been talking about his memories
and ruminations and the conclusions that
he's drawn from them for you know nine
books now and now he's going into
another book talking about uh this
incredibly important
central dimension of ourselves and he
uses a lot of really interesting
language it's you know i'm calling it
here an extensive power of the mind
that's rather abstract he talks about
the vast fields of it it is a treasure
house you know a thesaurus a place that
you can get all sorts of things out of
and if you think about
you know for any human being
at any given point in their life they
have who knows how many different
memories where how do we divide them up
and connect them together you know there
are so many we couldn't possibly
enumerate or even remember
all of them successfully
in the course of the rest of our life
and yet we take this
capacity
for granted he brings up some of the
powers that it has we can call things up
he actually has some language there
that's almost reminiscent of people in
sci-fi movies where they've got like a
screen that floats in the air and they
push things out of the way and bring in
other things
that's what we're doing
all of the time without even realizing
it i say
think about you know what augustine said
in book six and you don't have to like
you know do processing now like here's
some sort of robot or computer it just
pops into your head or or you might say
i haven't read augustine's book six but
i remember dr sailors really into
augustine boom there's a memory right
so
memory is is incredibly um powerful and
the question that we want to ask is well
how far does it go
what can memory
actually extend to and this is where it
gets
really really interesting you know he
says great is the power of memory
exceeding graded is an inner chamber
vast and unbounded who has penetrated to
its very bottom yet it's a power of my
mind it belongs to my nature and thus i
do not comprehend all that i am is it
the mind is the mind therefore too
limited to possess itself right so
what's included
he tells us think about the sense images
right
imagine a
you know
violet the flower and if you've ever
smelled it imagine the scent of violets
you put your nose down to it we used to
have them growing all over the place
where i grew up in the spring it was
something quite nice you could smell the
fragrance you could also pick them and
turn them into bouquets
those are all memories
every single
flower
that you plucked
there is a memory
stored away somewhere on that flower
and the shape of its petals the
irregularities it had the way the light
came off of it all of these
sense images augustine says can be there
and sometimes it can get jumbled right
he says
certain things are
you know
asked for and others rush forth in mobs
and you know they can get in the way
and uh he says all as light and all
colors and bodily shapes are coming
through the eyes varieties of sounds for
the ears odors by the portal the
nostrils taste by the portal the mouth
by the sense diffused throughout the
whole body what is hard what is soft
what is cold or
hot what is so smooth or sharp heavy or
light whether inside or outside of the
body the great cave of memory
and i know not what hidden and
inexpressible recesses within it takes
all these things all these things that
are coming from the senses to be called
up and brought forth when there is
need for them all these enter in each by
its own gateway and are laid away within
it so a good portion of what we've got
are these sensory images put together in
different ways that is a very
significant part of memory
but we can go further
augustine says i also remember
the things i did i don't just remember
sort of like a camera recording i
remember doing them right and i remember
experiencing
things
he says
here we go
i encounter myself and recall myself and
what and when and where i did some deed
and how i was affected when i did it
there are also those things which i
remember either as experienced by me
or has taken untrust from others
from that same abundant stock i combine
one and another of the likenesses of
things whether things actually known by
experience or those believed in from
those i have experienced with things
past and from them i meditate upon
future actions events and hopes so
memory is absolutely central
not just to our remembering you know
images and things like that but to you
could say our agency our concept of
ourselves as
human beings so that's already covering
a lot of ground
what else does memory include
augustine talks about the liberal arts
the actually the precepts of the liberal
arts de doctrines liberales precepta
right so he's actually talking about the
liberal doctrines the the doctrines that
make people
free and and capable of acting uh you
know in in a free way
so what are these in his case rhetoric
has been an absolutely
important one but he learned quite a lot
of things as well
and he says um
all the things that i learned in these
which have not yet slipped away and are
put back as it were into an interior
place that is not a place
these things are not images that i carry
about but the things themselves
what literature is what skill and
disputation is how many kinds of
question there are and whatever else of
such subjects i know all this is in my
memory
and in such way that i have not retained
the image while leaving the reality
outside i took those things into my
mind i have grammar i have literature i
have rhetoric
inside of me
in my memory not the images but the
things
themselves
so this is you know something quite
important isn't it
and he goes on and he says uh in the
inches is in chapter 10
when i hear that there are three three
kinds of questions does a certain thing
exist what is it
what are its properties i retain the
images of the sounds out of which these
words have been fashioned i know they
passed with ordered sound through the
air that they no longer exist but as to
the things themselves which are
signified by those sounds i didn't
attain to them by a bodily sense nor did
i describe them anywhere in my mind yet
i stored them away in my memory
as those things themselves so the
questions the principles all of these
things that go into the types of
knowledge that we have
at least most kinds of knowledge because
we're going to get to another important
kind of knowledge in just a moment
they're stored in our memory
then there's mathematics
augustine will have an entirely
separate chapter
devoted to
principles and laws of numbers and
dimensions this is you know the
mathematics of the time he says these
are not colored nor do they give out
sound or odor nor are they tasted or
touched
i've heard the sound of the words by
which these are signified but the sounds
are one thing and the things are another
the sounds are in greek or in latin but
the things are neither greek or latin or
any kind of language i've seen lines
drawn by builders even lines so fine is
to be spiders threads but other lines
those of dimensions are different
they're not images of which the eye
has told me
we perceive them in ourselves we know
them
they are in our
memory
we also have
memory of the previous acts of our mind
a little bit later on augustine will
talk about how even forgetting is in a
certain sense in the memory
we're not going to focus on that because
that's a little paradoxical
what are other acts of the mind
he says i've heard many things that have
been fallaciously argued
and i retain them in memory i know that
they're actually
false or fallacious because i remember
that
even if those things are false it's not
false that i have remembered them
i remember that i distinguished between
those two true doctrines and the false
things said against them it's one thing
that i now perceive that i make this
distinction another to remember that i
often made the distinction when i
thought about them
therefore i remember that i've
understood them and i store our way in
memory what i now discern and understand
so all these things perceive distinguish
discern understand
these are cognitive acts of the mind
and i remember
having done those even
if the things that they were about were
non-existent imaginary false
misleading
they're still there
in my memory
so if we've got
cognitive acts of the mind what about
affective or emotional or
we could say desirous or volitional
acts of the mind affections as he's
going to call it of the mind well he
talks about that as well the same memory
contains the affections of my mind
not in that manner in which the mind
itself has them at the time it
experiences them
but in a different manner and there's
something paradoxical to explore here he
can says i remember
being joyful or i remember joy without
that making me joyful
necessarily right now although there are
plenty of cases where we might remember
something we enjoyed in the past and we
feel good about it right and so the
affections of the mind
the feelings the desires the fears
those are things that we remember
as well so you see just what a massive
scope
memory is going to have
and
later on in the
book he's going to go on
and try to think about
the happy life what it is that we
all truly desire is that in the memory
if it is why don't we remember it and
he's going to conclude that the happy
life is in a certain sense
you know the thing that we all seek it
is
in our memory but it has to be clarified
it has to be
understood and this is going to lead him
to try to seek out whether
truth itself lies in the memory and
whether god himself
lies within the memory but that goes a
little bit beyond the scope of these
initial
discussions of this incredibly
powerful
and you know
multifaceted
faculty of the human mind that is our
memory which we so easily take for
granted
because we use it all the time without
considering
what it really is and what it can do
you